poland has declared parts of eu law
unconstitutional
a majority of meps called on the
commission to take legal steps against
warsaw under article 7 of the eu treaty
and trigger a mechanism which could see
eu funding cuts
as world leaders prepare for the un cop
26 climate conference parliament said
the world is not doing enough and called
for the eu to set even bolder climate
targets
food and farming create as much as 30
percent of all of the world's greenhouse
gas emissions
parliament presented proposals on how to
make food healthier and the supply chain
fairer and more sustainable
research
health climate action building a
stronger eu for the future means
investment
parliament pushed for a 171.8
billion euro budget for next year 2.7
billion euros more than the commission's
proposal
in 2020 europe's cultural and creative
sectors lost
199 billion euros parliament demanded
more support for the industry eu status
for artists and minimum social and
employment standards for workers in the
sector
they also called for cross-border
programmes to support young creators and
innovators
[Music]